hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video Rebecca I'm monster underworld
again and today we're gonna be going
over and continuing our series where we
go in an in-depth guide for every single
monster a monster hundred world by
showing off the monsters movesets and
weaknesses while giving you some general
tips about the recommended loadout
spring for the fight and what to use in
your surrounding environment electively
if you do enjoy subscribe if you're new
I cover the in-depth guides on every
monster a monster on our world and I
also cover the news in future updates of
monster on the world and cover the
weekly event quest to let you know which
one to do and what the rewards are so
let's get started so today's monster
we're gonna be talking about is black
Diablo sand according to the game she is
a female and way more aggressive and
fast in terms of movement speed and
speed of attacks compared to the regular
Diablos and to start off according to
the report black diabolos weak points
are head wings and underbelly while her
horn back and tail are breakable or
severable for the best damage output if
you're a hammer wielder go for the head
and underbelly but more of the head
since you can ko the monster very well
with your heart hitting attacks sword
users stick to the underbelly and ranged
users go for the wings moving on over
black Diablos is a weakest to ice and
water for elements while paralysis being
the best choice for ailments
for the recommended loadout bringing the
essentials like mega and max potions
vitality metal to negate some damage and
if you have the Rocksteady mantle that
will also work too one very key
important item for this fight though a
screamer pods using this when black
Diablos does her burrow attack will
cause her to arise from the ground
giving you some free hits as shown in
the background right now of course if
you want to bring other things like
diamond drugs hard shell powder that's
entirely up to you
since black Davos hits a lot harder than
the normal version now that's over let's
get into her move set first is this two
combo head swing whereas the name stage
she swings her head twice to hit you
with it first going from right to left
then left to right in the same direction
every time dodge rolling on these moves
works perfectly fine or our sprint
jumping also works if you want to be a
little bit more cautious
you can tell what she does this move
because she steps back a little bit and
then she shows the move as shown in the
clip her next move is a head rush attack
where she rushes at you headfirst so she
can knock you over she will usually jump
around and face you once she does this
move and the same principle applies as
the other one
dodge rolling and sprint jumping and
you'll be just fine next up is her in
from his burrow attack and this actually
has three versions which we'll get into
in a second but bay
the gist of the move is that she burrows
underneath the ground and then arises
when she gets near an opponent whether
that be your palico you or a teammate
and then tries to smack you from
underneath by arising the first
variation or version of this is the
normal one and most people are familiar
with this one where all she does is just
go in go underneath the grunt and then
come right up very simple the second one
is also a bit more common but it's in
the very low points of the wild spire
wasted specifically in her nest where
she would go into the sand wall and then
pop out that way and then the third
version is specific to Black Diablos /
shell actually rush forward once he
arises and actually catch a few people
if you're not careful doing incredible
damage the best way to counter this move
is by either using the screamer pods
which we talked about earlier to stun
her or when you see the crumbs of the
ground coming near you use the sprint
jump and the invincibility frames will
protect you throughout the entire jump
next move is another variation of the
head rush we talked about earlier except
their horns kind of scraped the ground
this time this move is way faster than
the previous one we mentioned and you
have to be very quick on reaction for
this one now I don't know if this is a
coincidence or if this is actually part
of the move I couldn't get done in the
testing but basically when she did the
move she ran out of breath and stamina
and started just sitting there while I
basically wailed on her with my dual
blades like I said I'm not entirely sure
if this was just because she happened to
run out of stamina from the move or was
just a coincidence I have no entire clue
but take that as you will next up is her
shoulder bashed shoe being a weird
squatting stance where her legs are far
apart and then she will charge at you
went to her left
dealing incredible damage last move is
her tail swipe she triggers this move by
looking back and then swiping her tail
in the same direction that being top
left to bottom right and then top right
to bottom left or you could just look in
the clip for a more visual
representation if you're a little bit
confused on my explanation now that we
are done with this area let's go over
some general recap tips in area coverage
so the tips that I have is just one
simple one and that's just to keep the
screamer pods on stock she hates the
noise which causes her to arise from the
ground and that allows you to get some
free hits there isn't a lot of free hit
time in a free window Butler is
definitely some time to get in some
damage and then for the area since
you're most likely going to be fighting
her any wild spire waste in the bottom
layers there is flash bugs you can use
on her and you can blind her as well and
then on the upper layer there's a bunch
of rocks just laying there which you can
have her knock into and basically
knock herself out once again giving you
more free hits of damage and that guy is
gonna be end of the video today guys so
like the V if you do enjoy subscriber
free new like I said I covered the in
depth guides for every monster and
Monster Hunter world
I also cover the news and future updates
of Monster Hunter world and what's
coming in future patches as well as
covering the weekly event quests to let
you know which ones to do and what the
rewards are and just how to do them and
how to be most efficient with them my
two most recent videos are going to be
on screen if you guys want to check that
out and with that guys hope if agree
yesterday thank you for watching the
video and peace out